Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live.
Before we get started, I wanna take a
little bit of time just to say thank
you to Equinix Medal. Equinix Medal is my
employer and they donate the time and resources
that I need to put the show together.
So thank you very much Equinix Medal.
Equinix Medal is a bare metal cloud
and we are offering you $50 in credit
so you can try it out yourself. The
code is Rawkode dash live.
This will allow you to spin up our
smallest instance for up to a hundred hours,
but of course it's much more fun to
play with the larger instances and take advantage
of those NVMe disks
up to 400 gig of RAM and crazy
CPUs.
So use the money wisely or unwisely depending
on how you're feeling.
If you wanna chat about anything that we
talk about in today's episode or any other
episodes, do have a discord server. Feel free
to join us and you know, keep the
conversation going. Very useful if you're not watching
live.
Please remember to subscribe to the channel and
thumbs up the video if you can and
you enjoy it. This just helps other people
discover the content too.
Today we are doing part two of the
Cilium episode. Last time we had a few
problems which we've now correctly fixed and we're
gonna explore Cilium and see how it can
make our lives better.
And for that, I am joined once again
by
Ilya. Hello, Ilya.
Hello, David. How are doing? I'm very well.
Thank you. I'm excited. I wanna, you know,
properly kick the tires on Cilium this time
and and see what I can do for
my my Kubernetes c and I.
Yeah. I'm I'm glad that I was working
now. It's just at
the end of the day,
we have the extra parameters and and
and and it's working. The thing about it
was that we are basically bringing it up
in a new environment that hadn't been tested
before. Right? Exactly.
Yeah. I mean Or even
Bare mail is not as simple as as
other environments, you know. There's a lot of
extra bit of tweaking that needs to be
needs to be done, we've got that working.
I think it would be really cool if
we just start and talk about the the
news that I've seen dropping on Twitter yesterday.
Oh, yeah. Of course. So let me do
that.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
That one. Yes.
Very cool. Yeah. Ice Cilium has raised 29,000,000
in funding from various investors.
This is series a,
and we
are launching our enterprise
offering as well.
If you if you could could show the
the website in the next tab there. Yeah.
So if you go to icll.com,
you can find out about Cilium
Enterprise and how it differs from Cilium open
source.
You can also see some of our customers
and
read about the team and, you know, find
out the the openings that we might have,
and we do have a few.
Yeah. We cannot time these two episodes
as turned up as well, I guess. And
the the last time was just after Google
made their announcement about, you know, Cilium on
on JKE. And then randomly,
yesterday, the news dropped up at the CDC
and I was like, wow.
Really? A good timing. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. So, yeah, Cilium Enterprise,
you know I mean, we're we're gonna be
playing with open source today, but maybe you
wanna just give a quick touch a bit
about it. Mostly.
Cilium Enterprise offers additional features for
for enterprise security teams,
We're effectively enabling
flow logging
to systems like Splunk
and
and a few other feature features that are
summarized on the
on the product page. So if you if
you click on
the top navigation product
so just at the bottom there, there's a
there's a there's a long summary of of
the
enterprise features.
It just keeps scrolling.
So, like, for example, here so in in
terms of core functionality, it's all the same.
Then as you get into to our functionality,
Cilium Enterprise has additional support for for for
third party BGP integrations.
And in some of the other sections, you
will see that
there are exclusive enterprise features.
Yeah.
Nice. Yeah. No problem. Yeah.
Alright. So today,
let's
cover where we are. So I'd I like
to do very little upfront on the show.
But we do need a Kubernetes cluster. And
assuming nothing is broken since I spun this
up. Good. We are currently in a position
where I've used cluster API.
We only have one control plane node and
all the worker nodes are currently not ready.
That's because they won't be considered ready until
we deploy Cilium and there's networking in our
cluster.
One thing I did different from last time
is that I think this may be useful
to other people, so this code now is
all available on getlab.com.
Really needs to stop the tab suspenders, shouldn't
I? Getlab.com/rawcode/equinox-metal-examples.
There's a Cilium directory with the cluster API
code and the Cilium configuration, so people can
check that out and run it themselves.
I'm just using helm template,
which is spitting out the Cilium.YAML
here. So step one for us, we're just
gonna get this applied to the cluster. We're
gonna run the connectivity checks. This is stuff
that we did last time. Only this time
it's gonna work. He says confidently.
So
let's get Cilium on this cluster.
One, two, three.
Oh, it helps if I create the namespace.
I think that would help.
Alright. There we go. So
let's just keep an eye on that for
now.
We have a little watch.
Did you say you could also use resource
sets for this or
what time do we try You definitely can
use cluster resource sets.
I just didn't use them here because it
would automatically deploy it to our cluster and
I wanted to do the apply it live.
I should use the right namespace.
Sure. Yeah. You're supposed to be keeping me
right here. Come on. Right.
There you go. Okay.
That's that's happening. Yeah. That's happening. So we
cut our use cluster resource sets, and I
will actually put an example of that up
Mhmm. Tomorrow
because Jason and I are taking over
the CNCF Twitch channel doing Oh, cool. API
stuff. At least for an hour anyway. So
the quotes from that will be also in
the repository.
Now it looks like
it's happy.
Oh, great. Yeah. So now we can
apply.
I I added adjust target for this.
That is just
Well deploying.
Yeah.
This
So that your adjust file and, like I
mean, does it support a subset of makes
insights?
Yeah. So I I I I
I generally try and use make files whenever
possible. But there are some really cool semantics
adjust that just you can't really do. Like,
you know, specifying
and laying bash scripts is really cool. Which
means like like an interpreter because when I
tried to do this with raw make,
read an echo uses the built ends of
bash.
And I know I could have changed the
shell and make but then it's Yeah. Sometimes
it's just nicer to use just file. So
Yeah. It's a cool tool.
Okay. So we wanna confirm
that those tests are happy.
So no
restarts all running. This is what we expect.
Right? That's that's me that's to you as
a healthy running Cilium
install.
Yeah. Looks great. Yeah. Yeah.
All of them are happy
as in ready.
Yeah. There you go. Nine minutes and then
we've already made a lot more progress. Nice.
Okay.
Let's
just delete all those resources.
I didn't add a just target for that.
I really should've. Yeah.
And they're gone. Okay.
So let's pop over to the docs.
Now,
the last time we did this episode,
we started to talk about the Star Wars
example.
Is that where you wanna start today? Or
Yeah.
That means I'm gonna have to remember where
that lived.
Yeah. I think
I think it was policy. Oh,
maybe. Yeah. Yeah. That's that's right. It should
be there. Yeah.
No. I think I was wrong. Let's try.
Yeah.
Getting started.
And then
I'll find it. I'll remember. There we go.
It was this, wasn't it? Yeah.
K. Deploy the demo application.
So this is a Star Wars inspired example.
It has three microservices,
a duster, a tie fighter, and the x
wing.
Mhmm.
Okay.
So if I just copy
the first lane and then we can talk
about what that's actually deployed.
There we go.
And before I go deploying things to my
local cluster I should just
make sure that I don't accidentally do that.
Okay.
So
off it goes.
Okay.
I like it when things work.
So
I just want me to pull out the
pause and the s v c. So we'll
just make sure that all that look good.
We got a desktop service.
Excellent.
And
this one's means list.
Yeah. I don't understand why why it's asking
me to do this. Oh, we're trying to
confirm the endpoints. Right?
Oh, yeah. That's right. And we're using Cilium.
And I'm using a different namespace. So Yep.
So that list my Ciliums,
and then we'll just do the endpoint list.
Yeah.
Oh, I need to pick a pod. Okay.
Mhmm.
Okay. Alright. Do you wanna walk us through
that? Because I have no idea what that
just did.
Yeah. Of course. So this shows us
no. Hold on a sec.
So
this is for
for the Star Wars demo. Yeah. So it
it just shows us the
kind of underlying representation of
of the these demo pods
in
inside of Cilium.
There there's also a CRD that to represent
the same.
But, essentially, what what it is about is
that
Cilium allocates
a
an ID of its own for for
these apps.
Yeah. I'm trying to just get the same
information if you have one.
Keep it all get CEP.
Okay.
Is it namespaced or is it cluster scoped?
Would be namespaced.
Alright. So we'll get CEP.
Right. So this this is this is effectively
the same.
What do you call it? The the
the same objects that represented
at CIG. When we talk about a Cilium
endpoint,
we're just talking about some
network target, some pod, and Yeah. Network cluster.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
And we can see here that we've got
our two desktop pods that we deployed.
We've got Mhmm. They've got identity.
They've got IPV four addresses. They've got some
sort of state. I'm not sure what that
means. Like Yeah. So this just means that
Cilium is aware
that these pods have an IP address and
our endpoints that could be
requested.
That's right. Yeah. Alright. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
Now,
Well, let's see what the tutorial tells us
to do next, and then I can throw
questions. Yeah.
The the tutorial just highlights that Cilium allocates
an identity,
which which can be seen in that identity
column.
Okay. And just because I see it on
that list there, like, we've got enforcement
disabled. So I guess this is like, there
are no network policies being applied to any
of these endpoints at the moment. That's right.
Right. Okay. Cool. Alright.
So now it's telling us that we wanna
check for access.
Mhmm. So
alright. So assuming
this wants us to have the x wing
service blow up the desk there. Yeah. Mhmm.
Yeah.
Yeah. That's a good example. Okay. So let's
grab a copy first lane.
There
we go. Eventually, I'll stop doing that. So
we're gonna exec into the x wing. We
issue a curl request.
Yep. And it's sending it to the desktop
service.
And we're just requesting landing
and we get ship landed.
Okay.
Making sense so far. Next,
it wants us
okay. So we oh, yeah. Now the tie
fader wants to request the landing. So let's
just
Okay. Got it. Cool.
So we wanna try and protect the death
star and we're gonna do that through applying
policies.
Mhmm.
Alright. I'll copy and paste this, and then
maybe we'll just quickly write No. The the
command down below. I think that it just
that that would do the same.
I'm gonna do that so many times. Okay.
Yeah.
So this is our
network
policy. Let's get some syntax highlighting going on
here.
Yeah.
And we have some rule.
And this is an LCD l four policy
to restrict the desk or access to empire
ships only. Okay. Mhmm. So
when we're applying this rule, describing this rule,
we need to have an endpoint select or
and we're just staying whenever the organization is
Empire
and the class is death star that we
are gonna allow ingress from Empire
organization ships
and we can even restrict the ports that
we allow them to access. Okay. Mhmm.
Does it just want me to apply this?
Yeah. It does. Yeah. Yeah. It does. Okay.
Cool.
So
apply network policy.
Mhmm. Done. Easy.
So that means that the tie fader should
still be able to request landing and our
x wing should know well, our x wing
should fail. So let's try a tie fader
first.
Alright. We can land that ship all day.
And our x wing.
Nope. Awesome. It's just gonna time out. Right?
Yeah.
We don't need to wait for that to
time out.
Nice.
Okay. So that was
pretty painless.
Yeah.
So
yeah. And this is this is so what
we've done is created a Cilium network policy
object
that specifies these rules using Cilium's
own policy
syntax, if you like. The we Cilium also
supports the traditional Kubernetes network policies,
which which have
less features to them. Right?
So some some of the things that that
we
will probably see soon,
if you keep scrolling through this tutorial,
we I believe we should have
an l seven policy down below, which is
something that you can't do with
with the the
traditional network policies and Kubernetes.
So
let's just go step by step.
Okay. So we apply the LVL for policy.
Alright. So No. You you're on the endpoint
list again. Yeah. You could you
could probably use capital
c at c e p.
Oh, this one. So
we can see that
policy is being enforced. Right?
Did I run the wrong command?
Here. Enable. Enable.
This should be enabled for
something. The the output is a bit funky
here, to be honest.
Yeah. Let me I mean, I can make
it small. I think I think you know
what it is, David.
I think
because, actually, this
Cilium endpoint list
will only
will only show
the endpoints for the given node
because this tutorial was assuming mini cube.
Right. Or The number worked.
But, yeah, if you do get CEP,
that that will show you,
a better version.
So now,
endpoint state.
The policy enforcement
is actually not shown here. Right? Or
Yeah. No. I I don't see it. So
I'm gonna find the worker with the desk
stars on it. That's that's where the policies
will be. Right? So Yeah. That's right. That's
where the the endpoint will be for that.
Which means we wanna filter the namespace on
Cilium.
And I just wanna see what the one
is with
the four g
s m l.
And run the endpoint list again against Mhmm.
That Cilium,
which is
VWO.
Yeah.
That's right. So There we go. So we
have enforcement enabled here. Yeah. That's right. So
can can you do Cilium one point list
dash dash out?
Completely web host. Okay. Right. Yeah. So this
this is this is just local to the
host. I'll have to have a look into
why
why the CRD doesn't present this.
Maybe maybe it is actually shown
yeah. Actually, if you do
scroll back up,
you know, where the
get c e p up was.
Okay?
Mhmm. So it's it's for the desktop that
we
that's that's the the the desktop that that
we wanna see. Right? So if you just
do a if you put a get on
one of those desk desk star endpoints.
Let me send this back in.
It's just straight on one of those.
Okay.
So
Quick picture. Maybe
you could do a describing this.
Yeah. Actually, describe doesn't show that stuff. So
Okay. So describe
test star.
Let's pick the first one.
Alright. So we can avoid the managed fields.
Yeah. I don't see anything about enforcement
here.
Okay. So
I got something for me to take a
look into.
Because in the We test it. We've seen
it working. We can see it working in
there.
If I take on this, we see it
on the node one. Right? So the enforcement
is enabled. So Mhmm.
Cool. So let's carry on. In fact, it's
telling me to do get CMP.
Take a look at that. We have oh,
that's just our rule one. Okay. That's right.
That's the one we've created. And then it
wants me to describe it.
So as everything that we do with Cilium
I mean, does it always expose these
custom
resources?
That's just the way it works. Right? Everything
is
not me. Yeah. That's right. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. As I said, those are there
is support for the traditional
Kubernetes
network policies, which are inbuilt, but
the
these Cilium customers also are are obviously encouraged.
They have more features.
Nice.
So can we
what's the difference between an l three and
an l seven policy then? Oh, yeah. So
well,
l three and l four policies are implemented
in
on the
effectively enforced to the kernel level,
while l seven policies are implemented
with Envoy
and custom filters that we have for Envoy.
So, effectively, when you do
define an l seven policies, Cilium will speed
up an instance of Envoy that that
will
implement that policy, and
and we will be attached to to the
so that that that'd be like a
you know? And and we would be transparently
attached to the
to the pod in effect.
Okay.
Yeah. We we can dig into that if
you like. But maybe we could define the
policy part. So this this demonstrates how
that policy would work.
Okay. So let's run this now. This is
another curl command from a typhi error,
and
Boom.
We blew up the death star.
Okay. So we don't want that to happen.
Right. So we want to define an l
seven policy. So this is like, l seven
just means that it's pro protocol aware, so
it actually understands HTTP.
Right? Okay. That's right. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
So this is this is just an amendment
to the the previous
policy, I believe.
Alright. It's
it's using the same name. I see. We
have to to have a new object.
Okay. So we've got the same selectors
only this time. Yeah. So we can now
add this and say, hey, we don't Try.
Yeah. Is this allowing? So, yeah, ingress Uh-huh.
Supports Yeah. Cool. Rules. Okay. Yeah.
Let's
reapply.
And then back to this.
Okay. And now if we
do request landed.
That'll work.
And if we try the exhaust port,
we get access denied.
Yeah.
So
yeah. I mean, I don't know. Do you
wanna dig into how it works?
I wanna take a look at the annual
process.
I mean, confirm that there is one now
or something like that.
I I well, I I don't understand if
if I'm being
really silly.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, no. Right. Okay. This is the
request line. Okay. So we're only explicitly allowing
access to the request landing. It's not that
we're blocking access to the exhaust port. We're
only allowed in a sec. Okay. Would
that be possible? Can we say allow everything
except for this endpoint?
I wonder actually. So
yeah. I think you could use regexes actually.
Yeah.
So you could you could have
regex or the method or regex for the
path. Okay. Yeah.
Okay. So do you wanna dig into this
a little bit then and and and Sure.
Why not? Yeah.
So what's so
where is this end volume?
Yeah. So oh, yeah. Let's let's let's have
a quick look at that.
So if you if you go back into
that pub where you were
Cilium pub where you ran
Cilium endpoint list earlier.
You want me to go and save the
pod?
Yeah. Or you just you just try to
replace Cilium endpoint list with p s.
Can you say that again? P s p
s minus a f or something like that.
P s. Right. Okay.
No. I'm not saying the Cilium. Right.
Oh.
Yeah. No. Okay.
Maybe it's not a f.
Well, just l s proc,
for example.
Okay. Right. Yeah. No. You can see it
now. So if you if you l s
proc slash six six eight.
And take a look at
argument, for example.
Yeah.
Well, it's command line. Isn't it? Yeah.
Exactly. So
so you can see that,
you know, this Cilium envoy binary
that that has the
these arguments.
There is a file in the bar run.
Cilium bootstrap b b,
and and and it's logging somewhere. We'll be
logging back to
back to the
Cilium log, I guess.
Yeah. But I it what what you can
see is that there is now an annual
pro process inside the the Cilium part that
is Okay. So when I deploy this policy.
So they enter my cluster. Right? We have
an agent on every single node. Yeah. And
that agent is running the Cilium agent,
Cilium health.
That's I think that's been cut off. I'm
not sure what health part is, but and
an envoy or envoy. I'm gonna change the
way I say that every 10 minutes, I
think. And it runs an an envoy as
well on all the nodes. So the agent
is doing like what the health checks and
the rules and the enforcement at the l
three and four level, but all the l
seven stuff has been proxy by Envoy and
that's being configured.
By the agent. Okay. Nice.
Okay. Yeah. That makes sense. I got it
like
very cool. Mhmm. And I guess I mean,
that's is that just a vanilla envoy? I
can use all of the
different features of envoy for the
the proxy here, like No.
Well, I mean, you you could you could
do something there.
I can't
I I I'm I'm actually not sure myself.
But it is definitely not a vanilla version
of Envoy as as as we build it
ourselves with some custom filters because,
yeah, we we have to have some c
plus plus based filters that that have to
be built and built on.
But other than that, that's not like a
fork or anything. Right?
We build an upstream
plus all our filters too.
Well, it turns out
I think the next part of the tutorial
was actually my thinking anyway when I was
like, well, I I don't wanna explicitly allow
a single path. I really just wanna block
the exhaust port. And I think this is
Yeah. This is kinda what it's saying here.
It's like, hey, we can match the exact
URL or we can use
some rejects.
Yeah. We've also already described the network policy.
We've kinda seen that.
Okay. So let's try this. So we can
also do all of this with the Cilium
CLI as well. So Yeah.
This is saying I can run Cilium
policy
get.
Cool.
Right. And that's just the same route. Perfect.
Yeah. Exactly. Yeah.
Alright. What what do you think of next?
Alright. Now it wants
oh, Cilium Monitor?
Yeah.
But
perhaps
yeah. Well, let's let's have a look at
Cilium Manager first.
Yeah.
Well, I'm gonna have to And if you
know, I'm not gonna reference to it.
Yep.
So let's try it. Those port.
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
We can actually see that being done now.
Okay. So the monitor just gives me kind
of visibility into how the network policies are
enforced.
Yeah.
By the request
landing.
Yep. That was allowed. Oh, no. That was
denied.
Mhmm.
Did I get the thing?
Request
landing post. Oh, no. Because it's it has
to be a post, Alex. Okay. Yeah. That's
fine.
Just keeping you on your toes.
There we go. Shipland, dude. Okay. And we
get a Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Cool. That's really cool. I like that.
Yeah. So if you now
have a look at how the UI,
we should actually see some of the same
information there.
Okay. So when It's in the monitor was
the
like, the the the
pretty sensitive to Hubble if you like.
Okay. So
we have two parts deployed here, Hubble Relay
and Hubble UI. These were enabled in
the helm
Mhmm. Just global Hubble really blah blah blah.
And that's deployed a UI.
So if I do service
port forward
ICC
Hubble UI and that's just port 80.
Mhmm.
And that gives us
Yeah.
So if you try and select the namespace
where those
whether the desk star and friends are.
Yeah.
You should be able to
observe, for example
like, try and make a request from the
from the X Wing to
to the
you know, try and try and destroy the
desktop from the X Wing. You should see
those
policy denials
in in the log below.
Okay. Let's do that then.
There
we go. Alright. So that's unlanded. So let's
try and hit that exhaust port again.
Now it's done now. And from from as
well? Should
we be seeing something here?
I think not for h because that that
hasn't been enabled. There are additional options that
we need to do for that.
But if you do
this
Oh, okay. Alright. So the Hubble UI.
Yeah. So now now these buckets are being
dropped.
We should see these here.
Try and update.
We're not seeing it. Okay.
How
about, how about we take a look at
the
policies first anyway? We should see our policy
here in
the UI.
So this this is the the policy that
we've specified.
Yep.
And
if you go back to flows
it's not showing it here.
So they should be showing
Yeah. Traffic that it's
blocked.
Yeah.
That's that's that's some well, did you
Have I forgot to enable something?
Maybe. I don't know. Did we did we
debug this last time, didn't we, offline?
We did, didn't we? Because the last time
I deployed this, but I think I was
missing really last time, whereas we definitely
Okay. Really Have
a look at the
relay log, for example. Yeah. Sure.
Hubble.
Really?
Okay.
All complete. Not planned. Yeah. Oh, because I
can't spell selling.
Yeah.
Logs f Hubbell Relay.
There we go.
Yeah. Okay.
So,
yeah, it looks like this is
still not connecting back to the
back to to the Huddl port.
Yeah.
I think that was a
yeah. Remember we had to enable that port
for 22444244?
Yes.
I'll I'll I'll find this like message that
sent you.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's ringing a bell actually.
There was some phone with that port.
Okay. Yeah. I did. Well,
I think you could do what could you
can do is edit the Cilium config config
map now.
Yeah. Let's do it.
ConfigMap
Cilium.
Oh, no.
Keep doing that. No. ConfigMap
Cilium.
K.
Have a look for Hubble.
Enable Hubble. And what else is there?
Hubble listen address.
That one. Ah, yeah. It's all coming back
to me. Yeah. Yeah. Right. So column
four two four four, I believe. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Alright. So if I just
kick Huddl now. Right?
So then
Should I just kick everything?
Oh, just the the the the Cilium agent
pods. Just the
l kits up.
Okay. So the pods kits
equals.
Alright. So I
You can remember to add something here. So
expose list and address.
I'll I'll do that before I push this
code up.
And we run get paused because Cilium happy
again. And if I have logs on Hubble.
Might take a little moment.
K. Let's see if we can get exhaust
port.
I'll need to restart Hubble shortly. Right?
No. I think it's retrying.
Right?
So if you look at how we're gonna
log again, you see now it's now it's
connected.
No. Yeah. So I think now it's now
it's actually trying to do something. I think
I
think it's doing something that looks just about
right.
If you reload this once again
Oh.
Yeah. There you go. So you can see
the drop bucket over there.
Yeah. Okay. So Cool. Alright. Okay. Yeah. Because
I was worried that I missed something.
I'm always worried, Stora, but Surely this surely
this wasn't an enterprise feature.
Awesome.
So Hubble
Yeah. Okay. There's a there's quite a lot
going on here. I just wanna make sure
I understand this. So Hubble is a UI.
Right away, we can see
that
spaceship speak to the death star on Port
80 HTTP.
The death star has no egress. The spaceship
I'm assuming that's just because I used one
of the pods.
Yeah. This is the x one class spaceship
whereas we also have a class type of
spaceship. I'm just gonna run that as well.
Let's do
exhaust port will be denied but we do
have request landing.
Should I just refresh this? Maybe that rebuild
the oh, there we go. Nice. Very
cool. So I can kind of a nice
high level to really visualize the traffic here.
Yeah. I I love that it's even just
showing me
this, you know, the actual endpoint that was
last hit. We've got a 200.
Really cool tool for debugging our network. I
can see, like, I mean, all the times
we have problems in my cluster. Yeah. So
and the reason you see the HTTP, as
I mentioned, to to to enable
full visibility of HTTP,
you need to to to add a few
extra options,
which are not enabled by default. But
you can see when when because because we
have the the Envoy proxy
running,
we we can actually
in Cilium intercepts the those
h t p sessions already.
So so we can see the the status
codes here.
Yeah. I'm assuming there must be other traffic
going on here too. Right?
Possibly.
Does it monitor itself? Yeah. It does.
Perfect. Yeah. Of course. Yeah. Yeah. Mhmm.
Alright. Really cool tool. And I'm glad it's
not enterprise only, so I can use it.
Right. Yeah. Yeah. So in in the enterprise
version, you you have additional features
around export and additional
filters and
various other things.
We can do do a session on that
later on if you like as well.
Yeah. Definitely.
So I think yeah. That's the end of
the tie fair thing. What what other features
does Cilium
bring into the to the table that we
could maybe explore?
Is there anything else we should cover here?
Well,
I guess one thing that that we could
cover later, but that will require changes in
config as proxy replacement.
So Cilium has a more performed
load balancer that
that you can use instead of Q proxy.
So
it's implemented in the VPF course, and
it doesn't use IP tables,
which which have scalability
and moments issued.
Yes. I have definitely run into those problems
in the past in a former life.
So what's
so that means that when I spend on
my Kubernetes cluster, I can say, okay. Don't
deploy Cube proxy.
And then what what does Cilium do then?
How do I?
So
yeah. So, I mean, there there are a
few ways to do it. You can you
can deploy it into an existing cluster and
and and this so you can you can
now
basically enable a few options in Cilium and
delete cube proxy.
Right? You can do that perhaps if you
if you if you feel brave
today.
The
the other option is, of course, to to
to to not even deploy a queue proxy
in the first place.
But I'm not actually sure whether in cluster
API you have an option for that. And,
firstly, your cluster API doesn't allow us to
integrate with the skip phase section yet. I
know that there's some ongoing work to make
that happen, but not yet. But we can
always just, you know, nuke the cube proxy.
I mean, it's just deployed as a static
manifest anyway, I think. So we can always
That's right. Yeah. So
the
there is an yeah. There is a guide
for this that you'll In fact, yeah. Yeah.
It's just like here, delete that's demon set.
Yeah.
And in the in
the one nine release, we have a few
new cool features. Actually, if you wanna pull
up the blog,
Cilium.io
blog,
there's the one nine blog post. Today, we
used one eight as one nine came out
just yesterday, and we haven't updated all the
all the the flags, you know, configs there,
David.
But the
one nine comes with Maglev support,
which
which enables consistent hashing
inside the load balance effectively.
So you could
hit the same part if you like.
Okay. Cool.
Wow. Quite a lot of changes there. Okay.
So just, like, for sticky sessions and all
that. Right?
Alright. So let's
let's try and replace a cube proxy
maybe
in ten minutes.
That because I'm my concern is I'm gonna
get just kill my cluster, and then we're
done. So Yeah. Yeah. Let's try. What about
I've seen something else in here. Right? So
there was
something about DNS.
Yeah. So you could get DNS visibility as
well.
We can try this one, definitely. So this
allows us to
document a lockdown external access with DNS based
policies. So the DNS based policies policies. Right.
Cool.
Yes. There there are few there are few
things. One one option is that
to to sort of get DNS visibility
so you can see
what is going on in in cluster DNS,
but you could also
walk down access to some some domains, for
example.
Okay. That that's that's something
to try, definitely. And I don't need to
enable anything. Right? This is gonna work with
the
another install. Okay. So
I am going and I just you'll load
this. I'm just gonna copy it.
Feeling pretty brave now. Things are working.
Fine. Oh, no. Okay. Good. Yeah.
Yeah. You you missed API version.
Let me just let's just append that in
here.
Sure. Yeah.
So this is a FQDN
network policy, very similar to this network policy
of it. Yeah. You're now sitting
API version. Yep.
Have a look at the page where you
copied this from. This this is work for
v one. It's also v two. Okay. Great.
Now oh, so it's also using
the same labels, which is cool. So this
is still an org empire except now we've
got some sort of media bot and this
policy
is going to allow traffic to API.twitter.com
for
QDNS.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let's apply it.
Still feeling brave.
Yeah.
Alright. Now what that means is I can
run it's got CMP.
I can describe
FQDN.
And in theory,
Hubble
should now be aware of our new policy.
It is. Yeah. Okay.
Now
let's see. So this Yeah.
Let's go back to the document for a
sec. See,
I'm trying to make my own destiny path
here, and you're trying to get me to
follow the docs.
So I'll listen to it. Well, that's what
I do there. Is what I'm just I'm
just trying to
Alright. It makes sense.
I don't something
out again.
What's the okay. That's applying the policy which
we did. Okay. So now it wants me
to
use media bot and try and curl this
API. Did we deploy was media bot deployed
automatically for us?
I don't know if I remember seeing
No. I didn't see the media bot anywhere.
Yeah. I think we need to find it.
Okay. So where was the apply for media
bot?
There we go. Okay.
And I'll just change that version in case
that's important.
I guess, yeah, why mhmm.
8.5.
We just want it.
Alright.
I want 8.5 works too. Of course, it's
a tag, you know, a brand. So
there we have the media bot,
and we're gonna try and exec
exec
a curl request instead of it and see
if we can okay. So it's got a
few URLs here. Let's try.
I'm gonna time out.
So all of those are gonna turn out
except for
Except for API.rep.
There you go.
Sweet.
Good boy. Okay. So I guess it this
wasn't
an l seven rule. This is not Envoy
blocking this. Right? This is the pod is
not able to resolve
that host name. Is that right? Yeah. Yeah.
I I actually I actually don't know that
much about the implementation details of the
PDM policy.
Alright. Let's have some fun. Let's see. Do
we have bash? We do. So do we
have dig? No. Do we have apt? No.
Do I have APK? There we go.
Add update
DNS
details. I can never remember the name of
that package.
I'll do yeah. I I remember that it
didn't exist.
Oh, so
I've just Back in the day, you couldn't
get dig on Alpine just easily.
Well, right now, it can't even resolve
this thing. Oh.
So let's fix that first. This is fun.
Alright. Yeah. Now the Alpine CDN to that.
So
we can just add a new match name.
Let's allow it to do that.
Drop it out. Yeah.
And then let's see if that works.
Okay. Cool.
David, I worry that in Alpine, you don't
have this package.
Alpine dig command.
Think you'll find that
oh, dig. Oh, oh, there's dig. Okay. Easy.
You see? Unlike the other district. No.
It it lied to me. Okay. Oh, Bains
dash tools. Okay.
Okay.
I wish it was just like, there's just
some tools I need to be consistent across
distributions.
Like I've been to read out alpha. Just
want dig by DNS utils, it's standardized. Yeah.
Alright.
So that means Yeah. That
resolved.
Well, that wouldn't resolve anyway. That was just
me being really silly.
Well, that resolved too.
Okay.
So actually,
we
Oh, wait. Because I am not using cluster
DNS maybe. No. I am. Okay. Yeah. Oh,
and I think but they they try and
try and curl
that.
I think what it actually comes down to
is that it blocks it
a layer below.
It just takes the
DNS into account.
Alright. Okay. Now do we have visibility into
its hubble as well? Okay. Yeah. We can
see this. I
like that it shows you that this is
outside of your cluster as well. Yeah. Nice.
Okay. Yeah. And let's see. What do we
see in here then for those requests?
At the top.
Yeah.
So, like, you can see that,
like, for example, that one's been dropped.
I'm not seeing
the DNS look up at all though. Right?
Is that expected?
Right.
I guess, when
I'm just throwing a little stuff at you,
like, explain this. Why doesn't this work? Like
Yeah. So you might want to have a
look at
Yeah. That is only HTTP traffic, I think.
Right? We're not seeing non
HTTP traffic here.
Well, no. It's it
it's it's not that it's h two p.
I think
I think you should see the VPN here
as well.
Maybe this is
going
could you could you look at, for example,
the
system namespace keep system namespace?
Yeah. I think, actually, DNS visibility was a
separate
feature that
that had to be enabled.
It it's not important. I don't wanna Yeah.
Yeah.
I'm I'm just enjoying exploring
the networks through this Hubble UI. Like, I'm
sure there's other settings probably need to be
Yeah. That's right. Effectively, if you if you
use a PDM policy, the
reinforcement
is at the
at the CP level.
Okay. And then it's got an example where
we actually combine these rules so we can
see.
Yeah. You guys were gonna allow
cool.
And we okay. Nice. Okay. That makes sense.
So what does this this Okay. So this
looks like That's that's port 53
on TCP or UDP. So Right. I mean,
there is something
DNSC wise going on here, and this rule
is. Yeah. So if if you have a
look up above
let's let's have a look a little bit
above the the the document should explain. Alright.
Okay. This is all about.
Yeah.
So what did we apply to the cluster
then? Is this am I let's Is it
yeah. Is that part of it? Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. It is already. Yeah.
To end point. Oh, but we allow anything.
Okay. So we're not actually restricting DNS here.
Right. This is this is egress.
Ah. Yeah. So you're just allowing
allowing topic to give DNS.
Okay. So we do allow all 53 DNS
lookups as the egress that has been restricted
to certain domains.
Yeah.
So I'm assuming if I change this pattern
Oh, yes.
Actually, we're only allowed to resolve
Yeah. To star.twitter.com.
And then once we apply You know, you
have to dial find packages there.
So I should be able to do
Yeah. And
That's
actually right because the star would upload.
So that'd be that's really cool.
Try dub dub dub or something that
Yeah. So that should work, but Google should
fail. Right?
It doesn't resolve. There it And Alpine should
fail too.
Oh, yeah. I've I've not got much hope
for that running anymore.
Yeah. It's gone. It's gone. Okay. Let's have
look at Hubble now.
Let's
try.
No. I don't think it's there must be
something we need to enable on the Hubble
side, I'm assuming. Yeah. The Yeah.
I think there's there's
DNS visibility,
future over
So it does have this, like, the example
filter here does kinda suggest that I can
filter on DNS. Yeah. That's
we could
you could do that for for the
in the destination column, the the DNS names
there. So
Oh, there we go. Oh, there you go.
Okay. So this is probably going that you
That post names based traffic. Right? Yeah. And
wanna show DNS lookups by default because you're
probably gonna get a lot of that in
a real cluster.
I'm glad I clicked that button randomly. Alright.
So let's
see what we so here's the DNS lookup.
It was dropped
and
we were trying to look up
something.
Another one.
Yeah. So I I don't know if we're
gonna get the name of what it's trying
to look up, but
I'm sure that's something I'm doing.
I've had no idea. There's
there's forward dates. I'm gonna run it again.
Hold on. Let's try that. What do we
get here?
Update.
I don't know. Okay.
Just give me a second. Definitely see DNS
queries here and
Alright. That's a really cool feature. I'm I'm
really glad we persisted with that and got
to see that working. That was nice. Great.
You you found it. I didn't know it.
Yeah. Okay. So I I like that. DNS
based policies.
That's a really cool selling point as well.
Right. You know, especially if we were trying
to secure these clusters and stuff like that,
you know, if they can't even resolve, like
if we provide a wait list of things
or a low list that we allow to
be resolved in our cluster. That's pretty sweet.
Okay.
Alright. Are we fit that we've got as
confidence
because we're obviously just owning this now. We're
gonna do the queue proxy replacement.
I'm sure it is gonna work.
Okay. I mean, there there's other stuff we
can do here. I I mean, there's a
lot of really cool things like security you
know, Cassandra and Elasticsearch. But I really just
wanna start messing with this cube proxy now.
Yeah. Okay. That's what it says now. Let's
search for Kube proxy. Kubernetes without Kube proxy.
Let's make this work.
So we
are not gonna kill Kube proxy daemon set
yet. Let's see if we can No.
Let's see what we need to do.
So I can tweak the helm command.
So,
yeah,
you could do that. And I think there's
we could have a look at the
at the Helm chart source code and and
see what
the values are for this to to set
in the config map.
In fact, if you if you go in
and try and edit the Cilium config map
now
Yeah. Yeah. Let's do that.
You've already added it added to it earlier.
Yeah. I'll work out how to get that
back into the just file when I push
this code online, but we we can just
do it direct for now. So this one
says
keep proxy replacement.
Have a look at
that may be already set. Yeah. Prob.
Yeah. Try and set it to strict. Strict.
Okay. And then do we need to provide
the service host and service port? Yeah. That's
right. So because
because normally, we connect to the API server
using the
using the service IP that cube proxy provides.
But since we're about to cube cube proxy,
we're not gonna have a service in the
first place.
So, yeah, that's that's the
the one that we'd want to
tweak now.
Is this is this here in the config
map? Or
Okay. So Have a look at
API, for example.
I think I think it's probably not in
this config map. So let's have a look
at the
yeah.
Let's have a look at the
Cilium chart.
So if you go to
the Cilium repo
I mean, I can just rerun this. I've
already. Oh, yeah. But we are in well,
you'd want to oh, yeah? Yeah. Because that's
this is the home template. Right? So I
can just add these parameters.
Oh, okay. And we can just rerun it
and reapply it. You're not you're not passing
the throughput, pulling me or whatever. Right? No.
No. No. This is just
Yeah. And you but you also
you also want to change this for one
nine. So if you'd switch the doc to
118.
Yep.
Okay. So let's see. Does that change? Yeah.
Yeah. Global.
Alright.
So And you you want the Hubble port
back as well? Yeah. Let's do that so
I don't forget. So Yeah. If you go
to
Cilium.
Yeah.
And then deploy folder. I already have the
same as this last week.
Install.
Install. And
then yeah.
Oh, it's like, they've can have a change
that annoying thing. Maybe I get a bit
faster. Let me just get faster.
I know. I was just celebrating that it's
not hiding the folders anymore. That that was
like the worst change to get happen in
a while. Anyway.
So
I changed it one eight. Well Yep.
One eight. Mean, one eight. So I know
one eight five for the last time. Yeah.
Not values. Let's Charts.
Oh, values as well. Yeah. But want the
lesson at four two four four.
Yeah. So global Hubble lesson address?
Not to is it global Hubble? Oh, yeah.
It's global Hubble. Okay.
So, yeah, we've got rid of those global
values in
Okay. So now we need to work out
the Kubernetes service, hosting service port.
What what how do I get those values?
Does it tell me?
So you could get those
from your cube config file.
Alright. Okay. Okay. Gotcha. Is that is that
if if the if you know what's the
private address, that's probably preferred. But So it's
Yeah. Probably probably fine. Yeah. Yeah.
K.
Nope. Wrong file.
So we want this.
Yeah. 644 the
IP address.
6443.
Yeah. Oh,
service service has been serviced. Yeah. I think
so. Yeah. Okay. Well, I think this is
good.
Just just take a look at the docs
once again and
So are we sure that it's not just
the actual service address?
Well, yeah. Because
No. Look I need to do the right
namespace.
Let's have a quick look at the docs
just just to to
refresh because
naming is not a trivial problem, like we
all know.
Replace
API server IP. Yeah. No. Because the actual
you see, it's just the API server IP
and API server port.
Oh, you're in Usually, it's 6442. Okay. Yeah.
We've got the right values then. Okay. Nice.
So
that means naming.
we I
can just we don't need to edit that
config map anymore. I can save as fail,
and we wanna regenerate.
So just
what did I call that? Cilium.
This regenerates
our helm What
did I get wrong? Nice
error method.
I mean
Alright. So now
I can reapply.
Yeah.
And Cilium.
Ugh. My spelling.
My typing.
Cilium.
Most of that will be unchanged.
The operator has been updated.
We may need to kick a few things,
I guess.
Delete. You had the first first command.
Oh, no. It's already restarted. Oh, okay. New
operators.
Oh, yeah. And also the also
the agent. Good.
Okay.
So we can have a look at the
So is that Yeah.
Right. Can I go to Cilium proxy? Cilium
proxy. Yes.
Let's try and get get daemon sets.
All namespace is
cube proxy. Alright. So delete
and cube system.
Daemon set
cube.
Now we're confident.
Yeah.
Done. Could possibly go on. So
now we have no cube proxy on any
of our
on any of our nodes, which means
if Cilium is not working as we expect,
we have no networking.
So let's see if
Hubble is still alive.
It is? Mhmm.
Let's try
service. So And our ships are landed. Let's
try the Twitter.
Okay. Still good.
Well, take a few properties to around. Maybe
maybe it's, like, still terminating.
Okay.
So let's run get pods, cube system.
It's gone. It's gone.
That was really quick and painless. That actually
worked.
David, how did we not screw it up?
So that means there's oh, no. No. No.
No. No. No. No. Will still be IT
tables on our notes.
No. They wanna have a look if there
are any IP table rules. Yeah. Yeah. Let's
Jump into a node and have a look.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. But I can just get
IP addresses from here.
Yeah. Let's go on a control plane node.
That was Right. Working nodes. Well.
Okay. IP tables.
Yeah. IP table save.
I mean, these look empty to me.
There
was something in the docs, wasn't there?
Yeah. Let's let's let's have a good look
there.
So
done. Validate is set up. Alright.
Oh, yeah. Let's do what it tells us.
Alright. Let's let's not celebrate too quickly. So
Yeah. Right. Yeah. So
let's see what that's
I know the pod name's different, of course.
Any of them?
Shouldn't tab work? Different.
Here's Set it in my face. Mhmm.
There we go.
So We've got strict enabled on a key
proxy replacement.
We don't need an engine x. We've already
got an enough things going on, I guess.
Yeah. Yeah. No. We can we can definitely
tell that this is so you can resend
them service list.
I'll just type it rather than changing those
bits.
Sir, service server service
list.
Cool.
Yep. That's good. I see numbers.
Yeah. So
I think it'll save. Okay. Let's try that.
Yeah.
So it wants me to do that.
We can run that and still import, I
think.
Or on the note if you still have
the session somewhere.
Oh,
Still not gonna run. Empty.
Clear
IP tables.
Oh, just reboot the node.
But that will take five minutes.
Damn. That's what I forgot.
How to delete and clear?
Woah.
You can try a firecracker.
How quick can we do it?
And the immutable upgrades and such things. I
remember
sort of
thinking about the design where you would use
bare metal
and single VM per host
with essentially something like Firecracker
just so that you could get upgrades
by means of images and
and faster reboot.
Okay. So on that. I've now deleted all
inputs forward and outputs on test note.
Like, table
save
was the one that we
tried. Right? So now
it's just I'll just do it on all
the notes. I think maybe that's a little
bit quicker.
Mhmm.
So
let's do
this one.
Copy this again.
My finger is my SSH key now, so
Alright. Gone.
Last one.
And that means that our worker nodes are
all IP tables lists.
So then we can test our traffic.
Yeah.
Alright. So now we have no IP table
rules on any of those nodes. So let's
go back to the typefader.
That still work. Let's try Twitter.
It it it works. Oh, cool. Yeah. That's
Nice. Very cool. I mean, the only challenge
in bit there was just removing
coop proxy. It wasn't quite as trivial, I
guess. But you're right. I could just have
repeated those notes up at the being.
Yeah. That that would have taken longer. So
I wonder why they didn't do tables through
sat around.
I'm not sure.
Awesome. That was really cool. Yeah.
Yeah.
Let's pop that away.
So yeah.
I'm really impressed.
Like,
you know, I knew that Cilium did network
policies. I know there's the e b p
f rate and that's one of the hottest
things going on right now as far as
kernel security and networking
because of the just raw performance numbers. So
Right. Know, and that integration is just really
fast. Removing IP tables, you know what?
That is
really cool. I now need to go and
upgrade some production clusters.
And then that the cherry on the the
cherry on the top of that was those
DNS rules. I didn't know that was possible.
I just caught that in the docs. I'm
just like, that's that's a really good feature.
Yeah.
There's there's more various things that one can
enable as well. I think that table is
definitely something that
we should be able to part with
in the Cloud native age.
Yes. Definitely.
I I completely agree with that.
Well, thank you for for joining me again.
We
didn't break anything.
Things worked. I think we explored,
you know, a lot of the high level
concepts of Cilium. Hopefully, it peaked that people's
interest in it. Congratulations
on reason money enterprise product. Very very cool.
And hopefully, can do some more exploration of
Cilium and and then your features at a
future date. But you know, that was that
was great, Elliot. Thank you again for joining
me. Thanks, David. Alright. You have a a
great day and I will speak to you
soon. You too. Thanks. Bye. Thanks.